salut qu'à leur miami bienvenue dans les
missions qui vous permet de savoir
quelle journée
samedi michel onfray le film français le
plus lu dans le monde nous parlera de
son nouveau livre le deuil de la
mélancolie journal d'un avc et de son
retour à la vie dans la france des
manuels match d'affilée du requis
[Applaudissements]
décalé dit pas très bien tous les êtres
ministre français et surtout elle ma
femme entrée 6 ans dans la première
émission
stéphane plaza
grand standing de m6 viendra nous vendre
son film et on verra si c'est plus
facile qu'un appartement simon pas
j'accuse
non les enfants et pour toi une botte
dans le monde c'est la nouvelle star des
défilés simon dont chacune est aussi les
matchs dans black hawk et vise au
7 milliards de terriens et c'est lui que
j'ai choisi pour le premier ordi view de
la saison j'accueille michel onfray
[Musique]
vous l'avez bien descendu finalement oui
quand on a une philosophie vont même
savoir descendre des escaliers en fait
foi prendre qu on passe alors dit view
[Musique]
michel onfray bonsoir j'ai survécu à un
infarctus deux avc et un an des manuels
macro et vous êtes toujours là oui un an
de macron c'est le pire quand même si
c'est pire qu'un infarctus et 2
alors michel vous racontez votre
deuxième avc dans un livre intitulé le
deuil de la mélancolie journal d'un avc
c'est un livre splendide esi pas ça
parce qu'il met dédié je dis ça parce
qu'il est aussi dédié à ma femme fatale
lorsque les gens me disent pourquoi est
ce que le livre de michel onfray t dédié
jeudi parce que ma pensée l'à beaucoup
inspiré
alors tout commence sur un quai de la
gare saint lazare mais la sncf qu'il
n'est pour rien en fait elle est arrivée
à l'heure cette fois ci au bout du quai
je me suis sentie comme troué par une
lumière intérieure percée forêt
traversée perforé dans le cerveau oui
j'étais allé faire un tour sur les
traces d' art au mexique et j'avais vu
des clous d'utiliser les pré colombien
pour faire des sacrifices et en
obsidienne quand j'avais vu ses clous ça
devait donner une drôle de sensation
dans le cerveau et j'ai eu une
impression vraiment qu'on montre est
inclus dans le cerveau avec un coup de
masse
cru que j'avais m'effondrer cloud
obsidian
la cinq médecins différents ne font pas
le bon diagnostic et le 2 février 2018
vous êtes sur le plateau d' audrey
crespo mara et en vous entendant dire du
bien des manuels macron elle s'inquiète
c'est pas exactement ce que s'est passé
mais un peu parce qu'effectivement j'ai
eu je suis rentré immédiatement dans la
foulée j'ai pris le train de retour je
suis allé aux urgences à caen et le mon
médecin m'a dit le médecin que j'ai vu
aux urgences pas dit ça n'est pas un avc
j'ai appelé malte ou bible qui m'a dit
ça n'est pas un avc un ami qu'il l'était
mais il l'est plus c'était aux airelles
qui me dit ça n'est pas un avc j'ai fait
mon cours à l'université populaire le
lendemain y avait mille personnes j'ai
tenu le coup tout de même j'avais des
papillons partout autour des yeux un
terrible mal de tête j'ai fait une
conférence en plus le jeudi et puis
j'étais sur le plateau devant la tour
d'audrey en fait audrey vous interview
ensuite elle nous envoie un sms dans le
taxi en visant michèle d'ouvriers quand
même aller voir un radiologue quoi pour
faire un irm elle m'appelle moi j'étais
en train de déjeuner et c'est vrai que
je réponds à personne sauf à ma femme
évidemment elle me dit qu'il faut
trouver un radiologue appel gombert il
faut trouver un radiologue pour pour
michel et vous y allez oui on m'a fait
un texto adorable en me disant je vous
en conjure détourner votre taxi est allé
cet endroit où on fera une irm et de
fait c'est là qu'on a vu qu'il y avait
une vraie patate et s'était même c'était
un avc voilà là vous êtes hospitalisé
donc à foch donc cinq médecins étaient
passés à côté le pire de tous dit vous
c'est le docteur
parce que lui vous avez assuré qu'il
n'est pas d'avc mais ensuite il a nié
avoir fait un faux diagnostic en
maintenant fait qu'il savait que c'était
un avc mais qui vous l'avez pas dit pour
vous épargner des émotions
oui c'est d'abord quelqu'un qui main qui
m'a demandé comment allait manger du rin
alors je me suis demandé pourquoi si
j'avais un premier avec ma prostate je
vois bien que des relations entre entre
ma prostate et mon cerveau mais je vois
pas là le moment précis où ça aurait pu
passer ce genre là et et il s'est trompé
de wade a fait une erreur de diagnostic
il m'a dit vous avez un problème de
vitré donc l'oeil il m'a pris un rendez
vous chez un ophtalmo à paris cet après
midi vous irez voir etc et quand je suis
allé chez le docteur dont berne une
heure plus tard lui m'a dit non non pas
du tout c'est un avc alors les causes de
cette année c'est en fait c'est que
l'hédonisme sa bouche les artères c'est
ça
oui si on en remet mais il n'y a pas de
problèmes de tuyauteries c'est ça le
problème j'ai fait un infarctus à 28 ans
vous l'avez rappelé il n'y a pas
d'explication à notre avis un premier
avc pas d'explication deuxième avc pas
d'explication on est dans la médecine de
molière dans deux siècles on rira de
notre propre média fourier fois rude
surtout ce qu'on dira ah ben voilà il
avait juste pas un gène qui incombe à
isoler et puis voilà alors aujourd'hui
on vous dit faux pas ceci il faut pas
cela par exemple on vous dit est ce que
vous faites bien du sport ce que vous
faites du vélo est ce qu'on fait de la
natation vous buvez peut-être trop vous
fumez trop vous êtes peut-être stresser
les enfants dans leurs berceaux font des
avc et sont peu susceptibles de mal
manger du groupe doit rassembler
clinique ne pas faire assez de vélos
ainsi moi en fait en fait quand votre
femme est décédée vous le dites dans les
vrais pensé partir avec elle est en fait
vous êtes retrouvé seul un fidèle à
votre promesse il fallait vivre quand
même et là vous n'êtes ni à manger à
boire à prendre trop de médicaments et à
courir dans tous les sens pour vous
occuper d'esprit un peu je bois depuis
toujours mais peut-être trousses jamais
été ivres mais j'étais dans des
quantités un peu d'ogre et j'ai pris 15
kilos à 5 ans m et donc ces quinze kilos
personne ne m'a dit ce serait bien que
tu les perds des comprimés un médecin un
médecin ami qui aurait pu me dire font
un peu ça ne fera pas de mal prenait
beaucoup de médicaments c'est à dire
antibiotiques cortisone
antihistaminiques h1 sur plein de choses
oui fait des allergies ouais c'est ça
acariens donc le début de saison a
commencé antibiotiques cortisone etc et
on accumule une espèce de pollution
pharmaceutique et médicamenteuses et on
dira aussi probablement un jour combien
les médicaments tu bois là il faut le
dire aux gens faut pas trop en prendre
moi non voilà en fait vous étiez en
train de vous suicider à petit feu d'une
certaine façon moins je crois que
j'essayais d'être fidèle à ma parole
sans envoyer un coup de fusil dans la
tête je crois que j'étais en train de me
suis fixé des lancements et que ce
suicide d'où il ya un nom aux biberons
il va falloir tout soit clair est-ce que
c'est un vrai suicide ou voilà voilà et
si c'est pas un vrai suicide alors on
continue à vivre et si on continue alors
il faut faire d'où le titre le deuil de
la mélancolique voilà alors les
conséquences de tout ça c'est
effectivement vous avez changé de mode
de vie donc j'ai perdu 10 15 kg c'est
cependant bien le plus dur c'est quoi
perdre 10 kilos ou perdre ses illusions
c'est perdre ses amis parce que
effectivement il ya des gens qui ne font
plus signe des gens qui n'appelle pas il
ya des gens qui n'en a pas de textos et
des gens qui ont l'impression que les
avc sont contagieux et on ne se fait
piéger charognards aussi qui vous
appelle à l'hôpital pendant la dernière
interview de michel onfray oui olivier
les éditeurs savoir si vraiment je vais
encore pouvoir signer des contrats alors
au sujet de votre cerveau vous dites mon
cerveau s'avère être mon meilleur ami et
mon meilleur ennemi c'est vrai oui parce
que je suis sorti de mon milieu plaisir
mon milieu modeste milieu de mes parents
grâce aux livres grâce à l'écriture de
réseau à mon travail cérébral ah oui et
puis on se dit bon quand même là de deux
avc pour un seul personnage ça fait
quand même beaucoup alors vous avez
quand même perdu un quart de votre champ
visuel
qui fait que là vous voyez pas du tout
laurent baffie qui vous fait un doigt
d'honneur sur le côté là
or en
mairie de caudry qu'il soit là où c'est
le bord supérieur gauche
la mort rôde autour de vous depuis votre
enfance
vous êtes tenté par l' angoisse la mort
je n'en ai pas peur mais je suis est
elle est présente ou et depuis depuis
toujours un jeu raconte un peu que j'ai
eu un vieux papa quand je suivais mon
père avait 38 ans et que très vite j'ai
eu peur qu'il parte et il partit à 88
ans et pendant tout ce temps là j'ai
toujours eu peur que comme on arrive à
un moment donné où on se calme un peu
avec ça mais c'est un peu l'avers et le
revers de la médaille ou le recto verso
de la même fin et c'est à dire que les
de nice n'est pas possible sans un
sentiment aigu de la mort il faut savoir
que la vie est courte brève que chaque
seconde perdue est définitivement perdu
pour la récupérera pas pour la punition
elle est ici et maintenant qui a pas de
paradis ya pas de récompense ya rien au
delà mais qu' il faut pas rater sa vie
on inculque la vie ne repasse pas les
plats aujourd'hui le malheur le deuil
est traitée comme une maladie oui
d'abord j'ai toujours dit depuis la mort
de mon père d'abord puis celle de marie
claude après que ne fait pas son deuil
mecs le deuil qui nous fait et donc on
n'y pas un jour à ba oui voilà il ya une
espèce de feuille de route du genre dans
les 15 jours et se passe et ce à trois
semaines après un mois après et vous
allez passer parce si vous allez passer
par cela ça veut rien dire on perd des
gens qu'on aime qu'on n'aime pas on perd
des gens qu'on déteste on perd des gens
proches on perd des gens âgés on s'est
préparés à la mort de certains certains
partent d'un seul coup d'autres ont 15
ans de maladie cette année de
chimiothérapie pour marie-claude
non-stop donc évidemment il n'y a pas
une feuille de route du deuil mais c'est
le deuil qui nous fait parce
qu'effectivement il faut vivre avec ceux
qui sont partis et il faut pas succomber
ça avec son papa il soit succombé à la
mort des gens qui sont partis l'athée
que je suis se dit la meilleure façon
d'être fidèle aux gens qui sont morts
c'est de vivre sous le regard quand on
les a aimés et est en ce sens comme la
mort est acceptable
[Musique]
ah ah
michel
on peut la tenir alors michel est ce que
vous pensez que vous seriez plus heureux
si vous croyez en dieu je pense enfin
dans l'idée que je me fais de la
croyance en dieu il ya quand même cette
idée forte que la mort n'est pas la mort
et la mort c'est le début d'une autre
vie dans cette autre vie on va retrouver
les gens qui sont morts et qui nous ont
quittés que la vie d'après finalement
elle est en relation avec la vie d'avant
et si on a tué des gens c'est bien qu'on
porte si on s'est bien comportée on a
mérité son paradis si on croit vraiment
à des fariboles pareil on doit se dire
mais vive la mort écoutez je crois que
le plus simple c'est d'en parler avec
dieu
michel
c'est dieu qui te parles tu m'entends
dis moi tu vois encore fait faux bond
non mais c'est toi qui n'a pas fait le
boulot jusqu'au bout puisque vous
tutoyez dieu en battant il me tutoie
donc
je vous rappelle que depuis vatican ii
mais tu te crois que oui c'est pas peu
fière d'eux on lui parle en français
michel tu n'as pas envie de voir ce que
la vie après la mort réserve
je serais assez tenté par l'hypothèse de
découvrir autre chose mais ce serait
plutôt de l'astrophysique nom qui
m'intéresserait pas sur ce terrain là
l'ailé les monde inversé cette idée que
le temps peut être commandé un raging et
c'est à dire qu'on veut on retourne ça
comme le doigt d'un ben ouais presque
revivre al'inverse qu'on aurait vécu si
dieu était vraiment un astrophysicien ça
m'intéresserait d'avoir une conversation
avec dieu
et dieu j'ai pas la barbe mais quand
même je vais j'essaie de paires d'yeux
quoi michel qu'est ce qui te donne tant
envie de rester sur terre à part le
fromage le bon vin
ah ça c'est une bonne question
je crois que la vie en tant que tel est
une et une chose fabuleuse il ya en moi
une force qui me veut ce qu'une personne
appelée l'élan vital et cette force qui
me veut et elle est pour l'instant plus
forte qu'une force qu'ils ne voudraient
plus via les femmes si ça donne envie de
rester sur terre non
on change d'époque canton quand on
change de décennies je vais avoir 60 ans
le 1er janvier prochain le rapport aux
femmes n'est plus du tout le même donc
ça paraît évident que le les collections
qu'on peut faire quand on a 30 ans on ne
les fait plus et on est plutôt non plus
dans une logique de cherche quelque
chose quantité dans une logique de
qualité mais dès qu'on avait la quantité
épicurienne quand on est à 30 ans on a
la qualité stoïcienne quand on a 60 vous
êtes grand père
alors tout ça il faut dire que j'ai vécu
une 37 ans avec marie claude et qu'il y
avait dans ma vie dorothée depuis 25 ans
que marie claude connaissait l'existence
de dorothée que dorothée connaissait
l'existence de de marie-claude de
requins d'ailleurs été formidable sur la
fin de marie claude m'a aidé pour les
bouteilles d'oxygène de marie-claude et
total sont des choses qu'on raconte pas
vous
vaut mieux amener je le dis pour un job
et jeudi pour la première fois je suis
content que ce soit chez vous et il se
fait que oui dorothée à un grand garçon
deux grandes filles victoire et avec
michaël qui est un adorable garçon ils
ont fait tous les deux un petit augustin
qui n'est pas simple mais qui est
adorable donc moi qui n'ai pas été père
je me retrouve grand père félicitations
michel onfray
je voudrais te poser une question qui me
taraude l'esprit
pourquoi top 100 du temps à vouloir
prouver que je n'existe pas
je ne prouve pas l'inexistence de dieu
je suis dans une logique
judéo-chrétienne j'en suis je suis un
judéo-chrétien à 20 siècle derrière nous
de quinze siècles on dire à jésus pour
moi est une fiction c'est pas un
personnage historique et ce qui
m'intéresse comme philosophe c'est de
voir comment tout ça ce qui compte
vraiment et que dieu soit le dieu
monothéiste nom surgit crois pas avec
une barbe ou sans barbe qu'il est
d'aider des sentiments humains qu'ils
puissent se venger qui puisse
récompenser qu'il puisse tout voir tout
savoir ça pour moi c'est une fiction à
l'évidence mais j'ai pas envie forcément
de nommer dieu ce que l'astrophysique
nous enseigne
s'il ya effectivement d'autres vies
ailleurs si notre vie continue sous une
autre forme moi j'attends que là
physiquement fasse la démonstration et
si on veut appeler ça dieu j'ai rien
contre dieu ce qui me gêne dans le dieu
ce sont les gens qui s'en réclament pour
imposer leur mode de vie les autres
notre mythe kunz ce qui me gêne dans
dieu ce sont les religions dit michel
si j'existe est vraiment que
souhaiterais tu m'as dire disparaît
quand
y'a un truc à une chose à laquelle je
pense là la question colombo
[Musique]
dites-moi michel onfray ya un truc qui
me chagrine nous inquiète beaucoup
emmanuel macron on en bave à tout à
l'heure d'ailleurs dans la battle mais
chaque fois vous dites que emmanuel
macron est en roi et c'est même pas du
tout vous avez vu de crown non quand on
voit de quoi on comprend que macro n'est
pas un droit c'est au plus à un
dictateur libéral mais c'est parfois pas
très cool pour les rois de dire que
macro est un roi parce que les rois sont
beaucoup plus respectueux des
institutions qu emmanuel macron je vous
garantis que vous avez raison c'est
vraiment c'est vrai
je suis dans un esprit polémique dont
s'est noyé dans ce genre de tête donc
pour beaucoup le roi c'est le pouvoir
autocratique et moderne chez x et une
pouvoir d'un individu qui décide s'il y
en a quatre cebu 14 sél et les rois
d'aujourd'hui il se comporte beaucoup
mieux qu'elle m'a complètement raison
mais même louis saez - mais oui c'est le
ferrand pour le oui bien sûr bien sûr et
même pour louis xiv d'une certaine
manière va pas comparer ce qui est
comparable
weiss et l'anachronisme de comparer
absolument mais c'est une façon de
parler quand on a vraiment l'impression
que les révolutionnaires sont tous des
gentils coin les rois sont tous des
méchants je jouais un peu sur ça mais
historiquement c'est vous qui avez
raison merci alors il ya eu pas mal
d'histoires la benne un fait incroyable
histoire des bennes à la perquisition
chez benalla tient y va avec les flics
chez lui il n'a pas la clé on demande un
bélier au commissariat le commissariat
de laon n'a pas de bélier tout le monde
à se coucher y a pas un seul flic qui
restent devant la porte de bena là et le
lendemain matin quand on y retourne on
s'aperçoit que le fameux coffre qui doit
contenir on ne sait quoi a disparu et le
parquet refuse de poursuivre donc la
sphère est enterré oui donc on est chez
pasqua on est barbouzeries là ben oui
tout est dit exactement mais il ya plein
d'histoires comme ça depuis le début et
avec pas mal de gens il ya un ace alcool
compagnies interdites réhabilite voilà
une dame qui a utilisé des taxis des
taxis pour ses enfants 40000 euros de
frais de taxi à l'époque où elle
travaillait à li na pour ses enfants et
cette dame qui a été condamné à vue de
la promotion promotion macron promotion
soutenue par madame nissen qui elle est
dans l'illégalité aussi avec
l'augmentation de 2 sur la surface des
cdo et sa maison mais aussi la
nomination de philippe besson il vient
d'être nommé donc consul conçu à los
angeles
avec là encore une décision personnelle
c'est à dire qu'il l'a il ya eu un
décret qui a été signé par macrophages
un choisi est décidée pour qu'on puisse
choisir quelqu'un qui sortent et voilà
où du raout ya un décret du quai d'orsay
d'un creusement le quai d'orsay nomme
des gens à ce poste là ça suppose comme
des compétences quand on est consul de
france là-bas en joue un rôle
extrêmement important est le fait qu on
écrit des romans ça ne suffit pas donc
effectivement on est dans une dictature
libérale pour le coup alors elle c'est
au nom du libéralisme de l'argent et du
marché et de fait on peut se dire mais
les gens qui ont cru que macro
changerait quelque chose
ne se sont bien
placés pour le faire
jamie gregg
black bürki et simon ben j'ai pu en
quelques jours
il est où ma fille de laurent
vient
m
[Musique]
j'ai en moi
simon pierre
les goémoniers tort quand même temps on
est encore tu vas très bien défendre
magnifique a mis beaucoup d'argent
beaucoup en plus c'est nous qui payons
c'est personne donc là tu ne gagne plus
rien tu ne dégage plus pendant quelques
mois on n'a pas gagné beaucoup mais
après bon notre repère pour les gens
sera présent mais alors pas du tout a
changé tout est ce que toi tu as changé
et or écoute moi oui j'ai changé je suis
venu beaucoup plus humain oui nous c'est
vrai en plus son directionnel décor a
changé le titre le titre s'appelle les
terriens du samedi tu vois pas ce que
comme il est et revient du dimanche
fallait qu'ils les terriens du salon que
les gens je repère voilà c'est
l'émission qui permet de savoir quel
jour on est en fait tu vois
[Applaudissements]
on m'a parlé de yann moix où est il ben
tu vas pas
retour de ban test dans le blind test on
a pris une grande décision c'est à dire
qu'en fait tu vas jouer seul contre tous
parce que tu t'es mis d'accord
tellement fort
contre le reste du monde mais j'ai
beaucoup baissé d'être de mon avc 1
et bien un truc est nouveau aussi les
génériques et voilà
[Musique]
salim times est bien vivant et missions
qui nous permet de savoir quel jour on
est on condamné mi chemin entre on est
devant
c'était le nouveau générique ouais il
est vachement me plaît il est vachement
bien c'est super je préfère est ancien
mais il est pas changé et maintenant
c'est l'heure des récompenses tout sauf
ferment cinemizer jacques aillagon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
yann moix et en corée du nord avec
gérard depardieu mais j'en profite quand
même c'est une chance pour donner la
parole à quelqu'un qui ne l'a plus
tellement presque plus et finalement
j'en suis très heureux parce que
frédéric taddei est un ami et quelqu'un
d'une grande valeur
malheureusement il a des soucis pour
commencer que celui d'il ya quelque
chose pardon dans ce cas là pourquoi tu
n'as pas engagé sera d'eric taddei qui
est là les
frédéric comment ça va ça va très bien
alors tout a commencé en juin 2010 est
qu'en france 2 à supprimer votre
émission qui s'appelait hier aujourd'hui
demain et non non non non non c'est moi
qui suis partie à vous êtes parti parce
que vous en avez marre de bricoler une
émission dans votre coin c'est à dire
que vous et on m'a demandé de faire une
émission pour 22h30 des gens me l'avait
mis ce mensuel ouais quand vous venez de
faire l'émission quand vous faites une
quotidienne et quand vous allez le
mental vous avez fait l'émission
culturelle la plus longue de l'histoire
de la télévision française du thibault
est sympa il peut me remercier non une
mensuelle pour disney de 22h30 et il a
passé une heure du matin ils nous ont
forcés à partir d'une présence des
données une annuelle à 5 heures du matin
n'est jamais content je joue au pire
mais allez on va faire je suis d'accord
ça ne coûtait pas grand chose c'est sûr
qu'il m'aurait pas garder ensuite ça a
continué avec votre remplacement dans
dare-dare un format court culturel que
vous présentiez depuis 2002 voilà
pourquoi vous en dirai sur ce coup là je
sais pas j'ai pas demandé d'explications
ouais bedag vincent vachon bien la
chandelle en fait tout ça avait vraiment
commencé à sentir le roussi en 2016
qu'en france une fois avait déprogrammé
ce soir ou jamais votre quotidien de
culturel que vous avez animé
effectivement pendant dix ans peut-être
que c'est les gens avaient regardé
et à l essai voilà où ça marche et bien
non et on l'a même reculer d'une heure
moment pour que ça marche un peu moins
bien si
ça marche et que cette année dans
l'émission ce soir ou jamais mon nom
c'est c'est eh bien en fait l'idée de
faire une quotidienne culturelle c'était
formidable bon c'était une performance
intellectuelle de votre part et puis
après de réussir à faire à un plateau
comme ça tous les jours non c'est une
performance de tallinn arrêtez
moi j'ai été très triste parce que on
entendait vraiment tout le monde sait
que l'intérêt oui alors sa partie mais
c'était ce qu'on lui a reprochées
habiter tout le monde oui ça ce canal
télé il ya des gens il faut inviter des
gens pouvaient inviter sur le problème
mais je n'ai même pas que ce soit ça
franchement je pense que c'est plutôt un
changement de politique
savoir que le service public est
ambitieux et que là on est plutôt avec
une direction enfin de l'internazionale
alors non non non non parce que l'on
cité de nom vers note tout le monde ont
du mal il faut que j'ai été le premier
mais après le président de la république
est dit que ça existait une route donc
il est bien plus méchant que moi oui
vraiment donc il ya un truc que
j'adorais dans votre émission c'est le
générique oui à le générique de botton
trading
[Musique]
oh
ça fait du bien
en
il ya peu une fausse promesse parce que
ça fait un peu ambiance porno des années
70 et on a plus sur beat ce qu'un essai
que de réfléchir
c'est un contribué à la chute de
l'émission mais c'est parce que c'était
juste après avoir fait un dernier à
réparer
et là je suis bien sûr que cherche
kalfon est revenue parmi nous ce qui
nous donne l'occasion de répéter à peu
près 15 soit pendant l'émission
magnéto serge je vous observe et je me
rends compte qu'il ya en fait un plaisir
extrême à voilà à vous écouter parler
d'accord oui mais vraiment une
jouissance et on le voit d'ailleurs
c'est ce qui vous permet de dire que ça
me fait jouir comme vous même parce que
j'arrive au théâtre ça se voit
vous savez pas ce que c'est qu'un
jouissance à perdre je suis pas aller
baiser le pied de jean paul ii en lui
offrant un livre que j'aurais appelé la
divine comédie rejetée par les baisers
le pied moi oui c'est la faute aux
médias circulez vous avez des
z'allucinés auxerre
ça vous savez comment ça ça peut
répondre ça s'appelle de la malade est
intact mais ne vous inquiétez pas parce
que
je pense que ce qui s'est passé le 11
septembre 2001
et la version officielle qui a été donné
par les américains est
obligatoirement questionnable il y as
derrière ce discours apparent de marine
le pen sur la laïcité sur la république
ans excédé jose qui ne souffre
apparemment une forme c'est apparemment
le niveau des
jeunes enfants nationale selon qui cela
est une terre voilà pour le reste va pas
ce qu'on pouvait lui reprocher à léo
comme moderne comme vous l'a fait ces
enfants tout seuls comme vous elle a la
même taille que vous le savez comme vous
ça fait les mêmes études que vous de
quel droit vous la diaboliser le rôle
donné par les romantiques à
l'appartenance face à l'idéologie d'un
homme des lumières des conçu comme sont
propres fondements originels ce discours
ces documents on voit très bien pourquoi
il joue sur une évolution il suffit de
regarder les invités ensuite le
taisez-vous de finkielkraut génial
restaurants aussi célèbre que le jeu
vous demande de vous arrêter les deux
tibias et dédicace ses livres il me cite
de la part de taizé vous de les émouvoir
sans pleurs la rencontre semblait alors
vous avez dit dans le point cette
semaine la télé devenue une médiocratie
un système qui promeut ce qui n'est ni
bon ni mauvais et où règne le compromis
bcc alain deneault qui a écrit un livre
formidable saab la médiocratie il
explique que ça ça existe de plus en
plus dans les entreprises les
universités et je crois que le le
service public en tout cas de télévision
c'est devenu un peu ça ouais m'enfin de
la abandonner complètement toute
ambition est de faire du moyen
parce que c'est ça la médiocratie assez
le culte de ce qui est moyen tous les
moyens voilà ces moyens devenus ne
dérange personne va-t-on se demandent
plus maintenant signer mission bonnes ou
mauvaises on se demande si le fait de
l'audience ou pas en gros oui mais même
ça hein vous remarquerez il ya des
émissions leur demande même pas de faire
de l'audience on leur demande juste de
ne pas faire de vagues et bien bonne
punchline
mais tout va changer de ce que vous
revenez à la télé alors eh ouais et
voilà
ouais
or vous revenez sur russia today sur
russia today
rolex est là on dira t france frédéric
taddeï ne peut plus s'exprimer sur ce
service public est obligé d'aller
travailler chez poutine j'ai réussi à
tout jamais animé une émission qui
s'appelle il est interdit d'interdire
donc une émission de débat quatre fois
par semaine et vous dites c'est la seule
chaîne qui m'est donné carte blanche
voit la carte blanche pour faire ce que
j'ai envie de faire en ce moment à la
télévision c'est à dire des émissions
ambitieuse
culturel de débats où je pas habiter des
gens qu'on voit pas parce qu'ils sont
pas d'accord entre eux on va regarder le
teaser magnéto faire ch ce qui manque à
la télévision ce sont les vrais débats
avec des invités qui savent vraiment de
quoi il parle qu'on voit pas ailleurs et
qui ne sont pas d'accord entre ça manque
terriblement
alors réussi un coup d'oeil dans
quelques jours par semaine à quelle
heure
alors travailler pour un média financé
par la russie de poutine ça vous pose
pas de problème moi que je me fout
totalement de savoir qui me paye du mot
que je peux faire ce que je veux inviter
qui je veux parler de ce que je voulais
je suis le temps ci à un débat sur
poutine par exemple niche très
exactement que tu va inviter des anti
poutine et bien sûr comme dans ce soir
ou jamais à ce soir ou jamais certain
qu'il y avait un débat sur la rue si
j'habitais les pro poutine mais mes
collègues david jamais écrit que moi ça
c est évidemment les anti poutine qui
auront libre antenne et pour dire
absolument ce qu'ils veulent sur
l'antenne de rtl front d'accord alors
quand même rt france donc a fait l'objet
d'un avertissement duché ça vous virez
moi j'en ai eu quatre halle aux grains
peuvent juin 2018 après la diffusion
d'un sujet n'ayant la réalité des
attaques chimiques en syrie point de
traduction et xenia fédéraux 20 la
directrice de la chaîne a prétexté une
bourde technique moi c'est simple parce
que j'ai posé la question on m'a
expliqué exactement ce qu'il s'était
passé c'est ils se sont trompés sur les
sous titres et c'est là où c est ça fait
très bien son travail parce que tu es
quand même dans le dialecte syriens à
aller au bout de deux mois ils sont
rendus compte qu'il y avait eu une
erreur et que donc effectivement la
personne qui parlait ne disait pas ce
que le les sous titres ou le doublage
lui faisait dire ça veut dire que quand
même ibos jean l'elysée refusé
d'accréditer les journalistes de rtl
france emmanuel macron son esprit alerte
et france en mai 2010 est à versailles
magnéto serge donc on va se dire les
choses en vérité mary château des
escoute nick ne se sont pas comportés
comme des organes de presse et des
journalistes mais ils se sont comportés
comme des organes d'un flux ans de
propagande et de propagande mensongère
ni plus on parle de france inter
et oui je sais pas parce qu'à l'époque
la chaîne n'existait pas encore elle
parlait peut-être je sais pas
franchement mais je crois qu'il parle de
russie à tous dès là bas en mer la
maison à nous en envoyer des jeunes est
ce que vous connaissez l'expression on
ne dîne pas avec le diable
même avec longue cuillère et qu'on pense
et je sais pas moi je crois pas au
diable demain à max lui croit pas en
dieu on est vraiment là aujourd'hui et
peut te crois aux deux alaoui moi j'ai
peur de l'enfer java prépare-toi
psychologique
[Musique]
et
maintenant c'est l'heure du débat de la
semaine c'est la battle
[Musique]
et voilà la battle le débat haut débit
avec ce soir charles d'ornellas ce et
aurélien cacher
[Applaudissements]
c'est terrible parce qu'en fait quand on
fait sciences po on nous apprend pas à
descendre des escaliers de music hall on
s'est un peu compliqué mais vous êtes
très bien arriver je félicite raté son
saut va quérir
charlotte dormait là dedans soir vous
êtes éditorialiste à valeurs actuelles
bienvenue parmi nous et nous allons
tâcher jeu député argumentant manche du
val d'oise bienvenue parmi nous
populiste la bataille de l'europe a
commencé mais d'abord blaco
macron salvini ne sont d'accord sur rien
sauf sur une chose l'europe est
désormais divisé en deux cents
inconciliables d'à côté macro se
présente comme le leader des gentils
progressistes face aux vilains populiste
que seraient hors balais salvini sauf
que dans l'autre camp on voit les choses
différemment
en refusant d'accueillir les migrants de
l'aquarius qui ont finalement débarqué à
malte selvini s'est imposé comme le
leader des anti migrants en europe reste
à na li ce bateau à ne verra l'italie
que sur une carte postale l'état ya là
bas parce que matteo salvini est un
méchant et que oui sinon c'est parce
qu'il ya des règles oui c'est qu'elles
doivent être
sa force c'est de représenter la
troisième puissance économique
européenne avec 70% des italiens qui le
soutiennent désormais son ambition de
créer une coalition européenne avec le
soutien du hongrois or ban et de ses
alliés polonais tchèques et slovaques
mais aussi de l'autriche et de la
bulgarie l'extrême droite participe au
gouvernement salvini aura même droit au
soutien de steve banane l'ancien conseil
de trump qui va s'installer à bruxelles
pour soutenir les populistes européens
face à cette offensive nationaliste
magron paraît de plus en plus isolé vive
l'europe certes hier à marseille il
s'affichait avec merkel sauf que la
chancelière traîne comme un boulet sa
décision d'avoir accueilli 1 million
migrants en allemagne
en juin dernier il a fallu qu'ils
durcissent les lois sur l'immigration
pour éviter la démission de son ministre
de l'intérieur et pourtant l'extrême
droite ne cesse de progresser comme en
témoignent les manifestations de
chemnitz même les pays scandinaves
réputés pour leur tolérance ferment
leurs portes aux migrants au danemark le
gouvernement devrait expulser les
migrants dans des camps en albanie
tandis qu'en suède l'extrême droite
devrait réaliser un score historique aux
législatives prévues demain
face à cette montée du nationalisme
macron bomber le torse je ne cèderai
rien nationaliste et à ceux qui comme
son discours de haine après tout il a
prouvé qu'il tirait plus vite que son
ombre en plein dans le pen au débat
présidentiel alors dans son duel avec
salvini il soigne son image de gentil
progressiste tandis que salvini sorel
l'affreux méchant mais attention dans la
vraie vie c'est pas comme au cinéma des
fois c'est l'offre méchant
gagne à la fin
c'était une icône blaco mise en image de
julien gracq alors le 26 mai 2010 9 au
soir on saura qui des progressistes ou
des populistes a gagné la bataille de
l'europe maquereau ou salvini or ban qui
va gagner charlotte d'ornellas ce lors
de la sphère de l'aquarius j'ai pris
position pour salvini car il refuse
dites vous de payer d'incompétence
européenne et la violation des
frontières de l'italie par les ong pour
vous salvini à l'issue de ces pseudo
accord de bruxelles a gagné le bras de
fer c'est sûr qu'il a en tout cas réussi
à imposer cette question là à l'union
européenne et c'est derrière
effectivement emmanuel macron qui avec
son allié à merkel ont essayé de trouver
un accord que d'ailleurs l'union
européenne n'a toujours pas trouvé alors
ils nous ont dit on a accouché d'un
accord qui n'a absolument rien changé et
la vérité c'est que pendant qu'elle va
nouvelle macro continue à dire seule
l'europe peut apporter une réponse sur
les questions d'immigration
salvini lui a pris une décision qu'on
soit d'accord ou pas il a montré que à
l'échelle nationale il arrivait à
prendre une décision que l'europe ne
parvenait pas à offrir voilà alors
aurélien tâche est donc pour vous les
cyniques ils responsables comme hors
banner salvini qui sont prêts à laisser
ceux qui fuient la guerre mourir en mer
nous trouveront face à l' homme gît est
là oui tout à fait non mais j'ai bien
aimé le reportage mais moi je suis pas
sûr qu'aujourd'hui on puisse dire que
ces macro le gentil aujourd'hui c'est
nous qu'on accuserait de vouloir imposer
aux français des migrants qui serait
dangereux pour leur sécurité une europe
dont il ne voudrait pas finalement
est-ce que c'est pas nous aujourd'hui
les méchants donc moi je suis d'accord
si le méchant gainey ça me va bien mais
je pas sûr qu'on puisse poser le débat
dans ces termes non plus sérieusement
moi je crois qu'en fait c'est simple
j'ai ceux qui veulent l'europe et à ceux
qui en veulent pas et ceux qui pensent
que l'europe ça peut marcher pour
accueillir les migrants il pense que
quand un bateau arrive bas le bon sens
et de le faire accoster dans le premier
port et ensuite d'essayer de répartir
les gens dans les différents pays et
ceux qui pensent qu'au contraire il faut
il faut plutôt les laisser les laisser
aux mères et moi personnellement ça
m'empêche pas de dormir voilà alors
michel pour vous c'est toute la perfidie
du système maastrichien terre de laisser
croire que quiconque n'est pas eux et
contre eux oui moi je parle au contraire
de vous j'ai pas aimé le reportage du
tout mais ce qui est une façon
d'utiliser les mots comme si les choses
étaient extrêmement simple on devrait
les progressistes progressiste déjà
alors qui est contre le progrès déjà il
ya quelque chose de 10 dans le projet et
puis les populistes populiste c'est
pareil et on pourrait proposer des
populistes ou populicide - karakus
babeuf avait inventé ce terme là pendant
la révolution française et je trouve que
si on veut vraiment utiliser populiste
alors allons-y avec les populicide le
choix n'est plus entre les méchants
populiste et des bons progressiste c'est
à dire entre l'obscurantisme absolue les
puits entre le progrès les lumières mais
juste entre ceux qui défendent le peuple
des populistes et ceux qui les tuent
populicide je trouve que c'est pas
exactement la même chose voyez déjà
comment la chose amusante et comme quand
vous nous dites en gros si on
n'accueille pas les migrants c'est qu'on
est contre l'europe donc voilà etc mais
pas du tout il ya une espèce d'état
maastricht ya aujourd'hui qui est ultra
nationalistes quand j'entends macron
dire le nationalisme c'est pas bien
c'est pas bien mais qu'il commence déjà
par l'europe maastricht yen qui est les
nationalistes elle a son hymne hélas sa
devise est là son drapeau elle a sa
monnaie donc c'est un empire c'est un
empire dans lequel les présidents de la
république sont transformés en premier
ministre voire en ministre vaincrons et
le premier ministre de l' empire mass
très chiant donc on dise vraiment les
choses on nous dit vous avez intérêt du
côté du bien le côté du bien c'est
l'europe maastricht yens si vous êtes du
côté d'une europe qui n'est pas d'un
mastri chaîne vous n'êtes pas un
européen si vous n'êtes pas repéré
qu'est-ce que vous êtes vous êtes
nationaliste si vous êtes nationale
c'est quoi ce que vous voulez la guerre
c'est à dire que mitterrand je suis en
train de lire le livre de péan
mitterrand qui nous dit le nationalisme
c'est la guerre et au bundestag chez les
allemands il s'en viennent nous dire une
chose pareille on se dit on va peut-être
arrêter avec ces pilules et que le
sionisme c'est la guerre je pense que si
le nationalisme c'est la guerre l'europe
maastricht yen qui est comprise comme
une nouvelle nation et qui génère à
nouveau nationalisme du par la guerre
mais une situation extrêmement
dangereuse
c'est une poudrière c'est total on va
effectivement faire voter les gens si
les gens votent contre on va leur dire
mais vous l'aurez quand même et on va
vous le prendre quand même c'est à dire
que on fait tout ce qu'il faut pour
frustrer des peuples tous ceux qui
disent n'attendez n'oubliez pas les
peuples ont dit vous êtes des populistes
et on continue en jonglant avec ces mots
de passer à côté de la réalité qui est
une réalité terrible un jour on ré
écrire à l'histoire et on dira regardez
ces moments où on opposait les
progressistes et b je
[Applaudissements]
sais quoi de cette opposition qui
d'après michel onfray est tellement
factice entre progressistes et les
populistes je me méfie toujours des
démos et c'est vrai qu'on fait toujours
des guerres de vocabulaire la propagande
ça commence par parler motu jouer c'est
comme ça c'est toujours de rendre ce que
l'histoire retient après pourquoi on en
est là quand on parle de la guerre du
golf par exemple on parle des troupes de
saddam hussein thema l'armée irakienne
c'est les troupes de saddam hussein
ouais ça en dit long couvert attention
aux mots un
vrai lien non mais moi ce que je trouve
quand même un petit peu un problème dans
ce que vous dites c'est que on voit bien
comment dans le propos que vous vous
défendez qu'au contraire est trop gentil
aujourd'hui ce serait du côté du peuple
et donc le peuple serait je peux pas
revu le mot gentil et blanc mais en tout
cas il ya quand même une espèce d'idée
de dire que voilà c est du côté du
peuple c'est le vont servir que je mets
pas forcément j'ai pas parlé en termes
de morale n'aimerais pas l'europe
forcément le peuple se méfierait des
étrangers forcément le peuple aura une
espèce de bon sens comme ça qui fait que
on serait forcément anti européiste
aujourd'hui où l'immigration sera une
mauvaise chose je sais pas moi moi j'ai
grandi dans une famille d'ouvriers dans
un petit village et pourtant à 12 ans je
me sentais antiraciste citoyens du monde
et je pense que je suis pas le seul et
pourtant ce que je
vous dis de mépris des ouvriers belges
étaient élevées dont j'aime à celui
d'ouvrier cependant j'étais antiraciste
un coût des soins que vous souffriez
surface et mans il y aurait un bon sens
paysan un bon sens populaire se voudrait
dire que on sait déjà que montre le
peuple contre l'europe mais c'est
aujourd'hui sa liste
10h indice pour les gentils c'est ce que
le peuple vote contre l'europe mais
c'étaient des votes du peuple à la
poubelle c'est tout ce que je dis et
bien c'est comme ça regardez le break
site le brésil ça fait pas une masse
heureusement qu'elle ouvre ici
les anglais ont voté contre et vous
voulez le breake si tu existes a fait
trois ans qu'on nous dise pas possible
toute la presse nous dit magyd
majoritairement nous dit oh là là ça va
être une catastrophe économique vous
allez voir quand ça va ça alors on
essaie de faire un break s'imbriquent
c'est tout doux j'adore le vocabulaire
d'un bric site d'où les orioles ou
comment les jeunes anglais sont dans
l'ombre pour manifester pour réclamer à
nouveau référence gens qui vont à dire
qu'ils donnent ce qu'ils ont avec ça
évidemment mais samassa dommage que
quoique quand c'est un vote qui vous
déplaît on recommence à voter jusqu'à ce
que ça vaut de base michel il faut dire
une chose et ce qui s'est passé quand
les français ont voté non en 2005 ils
ont fait passer par le traité de
lisbonne absolument exactement mais le
tacle mais ils ont fait la chambre des
députés l'an passé avec un rythme
congrès sénat et assemblée nationale si
les gens comme vous qui effectivement 10
le peuple on n'en a rien à [ __ ] il a
voté un générique a répondu
j'aimerais bien vous entendre quand même
là dessus non mais il ya une question
qui est effectivement la place du peuple
parce que c'est intéressant ce que vous
visez vous ai dit arrêtez de parler au
nom du peuple mais alors dans ces cas là
c'est carrément le principe même de la
démocratie qu'on remet en cause parce
qu'il me semble qu'avant que les partis
dits populiste arrivent au pouvoir ils
soient choisis donc par une majorité en
tous cas de votants les les personnes
qui gagnait ces élections n'étaient
jamais taxé de populisme or aujourd'hui
on essaye et parent
un phénomène qui joue encore sur les
mots d'associer populisme et démagogie
c'est à dire dont on traite toujours la
question du populisme du côté des gens
qu'ils représentent mais ces gens là
s'ils ont une offre qui effectivement
qualifié de populiste aujourd'hui la
démagogie elle est inhérente à la
démocratie en fait elle n'est pas
inhérent populisme ça c'est une
certitude c'est vrai donc le populisme
on voit du côté des gens qui présente
l'offre mais ce qu'il faudrait peut-être
étudier et encore plus quand on est un
homme politique aujourd'hui en europe
c'est la demande qui a généré cette
offre c'est du côté du peuple
effectivement puisqu'on parle de vague
populiste et pas trois personnes
aujourd'hui qui ont gagné des élections
qui provoque cette vague c'est qu'avant
c'est effectivement une partie du peuple
bien évidemment mais qui aujourd'hui se
présente de plus en plus majoritaire
dans beaucoup de pays et ces peuples là
on a souvent dit il ya une société on va
baser sa sur le libre-échange
l'ouverture des frontières en gros donc
économiquement libre échange et
l'ouverture des frontières pour les
hommes et la mobilité la circulation etc
on a appelé ça les gens mon auto
proclamé sa une société ouverte ça veut
dire que les gens qui s'opposent à ça ça
s'appelle quoi une société fermée mais
on peut aussi dire on peut aussi dire
que à l'aisselle de l'enracinement à
l'échelle des hommes là le contraire de
ce qui a été appelé une société ouverte
c'est tout simplement la volonté de
demeurer et ça c'est pas du tout une
question totalitarisme c'est pas une
question des années 30 où je ne sais
quoi c'est absolument inhérents à
l'humanité depuis le début donc on peut
apprendre à chaque fois que ça a merdé
on va pas prendre cet exemple là
aurélien aujourd'hui en france les gens
qui ont rejeté l'europe ils ont fait 35
% aux élections présidentielles emmanuel
macron a été élu sur une ligne claire il
vous proposera l'europe il fera l'europe
ça fait 60 5% aux élections
présidentielles en france donc le père
aujourd'hui le peuple aujourd'hui il a
voté pour l'europe et pour l'ouverture
que vous déclarez
monsieur dit c'est un menteur il a
raison on peut quand même dire que votre
façon de présenter les choses est
terrible vous avez vu le nombre de
millions de gens qui n'ont pas voté le
nombre de gens qui ont voté macron ce
que vous voulez voter contre marine le
pen ça ne suffit pas pour faire une
légitimité pro européenne
c'est clair
pour masquer d'après un paquet n'aurait
vu
oui alors c'est un petit peu facile
quand même de dire que quant à quentin
quand un président ne vous convient pas
c'est le grand truc de mélenchon depuis
un mois et demi un parce qu'il y aurait
pas eu à 7 soit on refait les calculs
dans tous les sens mais je vais la vème
république il ya des élections
législatives ce président a toujours été
très clair sur la question européenne
bien puisque tous deux bien sûr bien si
vraiment aux ils veulent ils ont gagné
allemagne est de dire que les gens qui
ont voté pour macron avait en tête
l'idée qu'il fallait défendre l'europe
maastricht c'est tout ce que je dis je
dit pas autre chose qu'ils font refaire
les élections je dis vous n'avez pas le
droit de dire que tous ceux qui ont voté
pour macron soutenait le projet
maastricht chien c'est faux vous savez
bien que c'est faux alors une question
une question me chérie tu as fait une
question sur une question le 26 mai 2019
quel est votre pronostic qui va gagner à
longchamp dans la troisième
l'abstentionnisme on sait que c'est
plutôt la fesci les gens savent bien que
s'ils votent contre de toute façon leurs
dires abat recommencera on fera comme si
vous n'avez pas voté contre n'allez pas
vous n'avez pas compris parce que vous
êtes des crétins vous êtes des incultes
zadeh pdp corps vous êtes des
régionalistes vous êtes des provient
sion vous êtes débattent moins 5 vous
êtes etc c'est à vous n'avez rien
compris vous ne connaissez pas
l'histoire donc les gens vont dire à
quoi ça sert il s'était quand même
c'était la même chose au président ses
intentions charlotte qui va gagner le 26
mai 2010 si on parle d'élections
européennes évidemment l'abstention a
priori à moins qu'ils aient vraiment un
grand basculement social comme un vrai
débat je suis pas sûr qu'ils aient
autant alors absents chance le dit
michel onfray parce que là quand même
une radicalisation le clivage c'étaient
des gens courtois être finalement un peu
une élection d'abord sur emmanuel macron
parce qu'effectivement il ya beaucoup de
gens aujourd'hui qui nous disent on est
très déçu on a été trahis et bon c'est
un peu toujours la même chose ne s'est
pas spécialement contre emmanuel macron
est par ailleurs ça pourrait quand même
être aussi un peu un référendum sur
l'immigration parce qu'on voit bien que
le populisme il est caractérisé en tout
cas c'est un symptôme beaucoup de plus
d'un malaise profond qui se caractérise
en tout cas qui soutient les pendant des
années des synergies possibles et ben
voilà à force d'être visible c'est
effectivement là dessus que s'inscrit
pour m
le signer qu'est ce qui va se passer
c'est mon anniversaire donc j'espère
qu'on va gagner
ça je pense qu il ya un sujet également
apporter jusqu'à la lie 35 ans de notre
but est d'éveiller williams a facilement
une abstention importante mais je crois
vraiment qu'ils peuvent gagner moi
salvini urban et le camp et qui peuvent
gagner et donc il y aura un débat il y
aura un débat sur un moment est-ce que
c'est effectivement le breakbeat la
solution pour la majorité des européens
et est-ce qu'on arrête avec l'europe
parce que moi je crois pas beaucoup aux
plans b et c où est-ce qu'au contraire
on se dit que voilà il ya eu la nation
aux 10es au 19e siècle qui a eu une
transcendance il ya eu dans l'esprit
national est ce qu'on peut avoir c'est
la même chose au niveau européen ce
qu'on peut avoir une souveraineté au
niveau européen ce que vous disiez tout
à l'heure et est extrêmement intéressant
pour moi je crois qu'au contraire c'est
quelque chose qui est possible c'est la
question c'est ce que disent des
philosophes comme balibar habermas et c
est ce qu on arrivera un jour à ça en
nous on europe je crois que le moment
est venu de trancher et que cette
élection européenne ce sera le choix du
retour à la nation ou de finir l'europe
fédérale de la parachever d'avoir une
vraie démocratie au niveau européen qui
permet de réduire ce temps d'attenté on
veut bien mais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
quand on voit juncker quel patron du
luxembourg qui est le pays qui fait le
plus d'évasion fiscale dans le monde
entier
c'est pas galvanisant règne alors c'est
pour ça qu'il faut rire chanter un peu
ce réseau d'accords avec vingt dix ans
j'espère qu'il va le maquereau à réussir
à le faire je vais mais il ya vraiment
des sujets sur lesquels aujourd'hui le
climat la migration le numérique
l'économie de services tous ces sujets
là je crois que les chemins adapté c'est
l'europe c'est que c'est ça qu'il faut
avoir comme débarras le 26 mai et non en
journée il n'y a pas de démocratie au
niveau européen c'est le cas aujourd'hui
nous jouerons le futur et chose avec
nous il n'y a pas une espèce de
dépassement de la france dans un projet
européen politique et qui soit en
capacité de répondre à un certain nombre
de questions moi c'est ce que je fais
bon écoute et mercy face on n'a pas fini
d'en parler on verra
charlotte dauriac merci d'avoir été avec
l'eau aurélien très heureux de
rencontrer mercy laraque avec push très
bien merci j'espère j'espère que ya deux
mois tout sera rentré de corée du nord
la semaine prochaine sinon je pourrais
aller arts et plaisirs du challenge vrai
nom s'il est volontaire et où j'ai votre
livre le deuil de la mélancolie sur la
faune est aussi ont traité les
genoux après la dure pour les puciers
[Applaudissements]
monsanto
[Musique]
bonsoir les terriens du samedi
de savoir quel jour on est dans ma vie
des gens au point
j'accueille daphné bürki
canadien et simon par atlus
[Applaudissements]
mais ce clavier s'est passé commande en
jeu dangereux l'émouvant oui meilleur
des morts ouais mais des sur la tendance
mais il va avoir des morts il va se
passer quelque chose parce que vous êtes
l'un des visages de france 2 je suis
content de vous retrouver aussi parce
que mes plantes et deux lapins
on est dernières années dont vous êtes
l'un des visages de france 2 vous êtes
aussi un petit peu les 111 2 vous avez
montré depuis le début de l'année pas
encore mais je l'avais fait en début
d'année dernière j'ai vu que toulon par
les dessins de constance moi je fais
tous les deux ans de presse et tous les
invités une nouvelle émission mais ça
tombe aujourd'hui
cette année vous avez voulu surprendre
en commençant l'émission habillé et
c'était un scout ou moins à parler
java sur france 2 hyper bien alors à
vous connaître sérieusement bah moi je
trouve c'est l'achat nous il faut être
vous va très bien parce que vous donnez
à france 2 une petite taille chauffe
classe et alors elle à son tatouage qui
fait qu évidemment tout est possible
regardez voilà un tatouage delphine
forêt val
d'or est compris et drucker et sébastien
se sont fait faire de même
c'est vrai que vous avez fait tatouer
sur votre corps le plan de france 2 pour
pouvoir vous évader
à
[Musique]
alors stéphane plaza mesdames messieurs
et dames des jo
meilleurs joueurs départements d'île de
france devant djaouad
samedi des vacances avec karine le
marchand très bien très bien ça se passe
toujours j'en fait et j'en fais j'en fis
et laurent petitguillaume il y avait
aussi mathilda may m'enfin bon karine et
une grande amie avoue très est ce que
quand vous allez chez elle elle vous
reçoit avec les jambes croisées sur le
canapé voile 3 elle décroît sur la
culotte tout va bien quoi vous n'êtes
pas obligé d'assister à démarrer ce que
les cultures dans la creuse non non non
je n'avais pas choisi la creuse mais
peut-être que l'année prochaine j'aurai
enfin le plaisir de son votre famille 1
et alors vous êtes potosi avec les
maquereaux ah bon on regarde
magnétosphère stéphane plaza il paraît
que vous avez dîner avec le président
brigitte macron et sa direction je les
rejoins en fait j'ai pas dîner je les
rejoins après un spectacle et on s'est
croisé on a échangé oui c'est bon
c'était bon et c'est des gens charmants
simple charme et la première fois la
rencontre oui mais cherchez pas un
appart non mais peut-être peut-être
ministre sait-on jamais mais c'est la
vérité on peut le dire aujourd'hui
trois préposés à stéphane bazin l'a dit
musulman
j'allais me remplacer hulot mais
alors jacquemus ça va
sinon chaque pouce le créateur de notre
français dans tout le monde passait pas
chaque muse de zola
petite vanne littéraire
vous êtes en cause et à paris en cinq
ans et on peut dire que cet été vous
avez été l'incarnation du génie national
avec mba paix et alexandre d'ennahda
vous êtes vraiment
est bien entouré irait très bien entouré
on va en reparler dans la séquence donc
ils s'appellent shopping où chacun va
pouvoir vendre ce qu'il a à vendre c'est
quand même beaucoup plus simple que les
gens viennent la division % général
[Musique]
ah
mais en attendant c'est l'heure deux
vidéos
e
mais bien et vous thierry très bon comme
il put alors qu'istres et qu'on a réduit
le budget
c'est sympa ça marche c'est comme les
gréements mais voilà c'est en moins en
moins en moins efficaces ont fait les
économies chantant pour trouver tous
cette saison vraiment sur moi c'est la
deuxième saison je sais pas comment en
france inter alors mais très bien ce
sont plus de plus l'histoire de nicolas
mas des canelles qu'il n'y ait
démissionné
on attend mâcon mais
[Rires]
attention c'est du zoo
[Musique]
heigl est génial génial j'ai passé l'été
à faire le double c'est très bien c'est
vrai je sais que vous avez passé un bel
été tranquille vous êtes resté bien à
l'ombre comme cariste et booba
et moi j'ai passé des belles vacances je
suis parti très loin et j'ai disparu
comme redouane faid et c'est parti oui
qui marche bien je suis pas pourquoi les
ai gardé dix ans les grâces
l'info de la semaine c'est la rentrée
évidemment et les pas folichonne pour
tous emmanuel macron en déplacement à
laval en marge d'une rentrée
cauchemardesque à titrer ce journal et
c'est vrai il arrive que des tuiles est
la démission de hulot la démission de
flesselles les hésitations sur le
prélèvement à la source allez à laval
que de soucis et là bas il apparaît que
les enfants il leur a dit professeur
c'est un beau métier et ça sert pour
être président jusqu'à preuve du
contraire on constate que prof ça sert
moins être président qu'à être première
dame mais c'est vrai qu'il ya un point
commun entre macro et hollande tous les
deux ont pris une maîtresse et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour la préparer
mais la plus grosse filet vous en avait
déjà parlé de l'été c'était la sphère
benalla d'ailleurs on a appris cette
semaine c'est cocasse que benalla était
en possession de la coupe du monde trois
jours après la finale alors d'abord en
tant que belge seaway je me suis dit
c'est vrai que la coupe du monde on la
donne vraiment à n'importe qui cette
année
est un peu je m'y attendais un peu oui
sur la presqu'île et puis j'ai
relativisé j'ai dit mon bain ils la
méritent un peu banale agir pendant la
coupe du monde il a eu autant de temps
de jeu qu'adil rami
et en même temps par rapport à giroud
[ __ ] à au moins quand il frappe il
frappe agressée et violée
on revient donc à lui que la vie de
cette démission bas surprise il a
déclaré après sa démission j'ai le coeur
triste l'esprit léger et la conscience
tranquille et c'est exactement la même
déclaration que celle du capitaine du
costa concordia arrivé au corps si si
c'est la même et son successeur l'a bien
c'est françois de rugy et là je pense
qu'on peut parler d'un choix du charisme
de la part de la grée le maquereau ou
peut-être que le choix de la cohérence
parce que françois de rugy pour ceux qui
ne connaîtraient pas bien il a été vers
et puis l'été au parti socialiste et
puis il a été au gouvernement en marche
c'est donc pertinent qu'avant de
s'engager vraiment à fond dans l'éolien
macron choisissent une girouette
[Applaudissements]
ce qui est important c'est rôle il est
tellement con et
et françois de rugy qu'est ce qu'il a
déclaré immédiatement il a dit attention
moi je suis un écolo pragmatique et oui
moi aussi qu'est ce que c'est qu'un
l'écologique pragmatique alors par
exemple je crois que ça veut dire que
après avoir été invité à un déjeuner
avec le patron de monsanto on lui paye
un café bio issu du commerce équitable
c'est quelque chose comme ça sur les ça
doit être quelqu'un qui utilise de l'eau
de pluie pour laver son 4 4 6 volets et
malheureusement l'écologie pragmatique
c'est ce que les politiques vont
continuer à nous faire avaler tant que
les ours polaires n'auront pas le droit
de vote
c'est autre chose que l'homme et la
nature
à gauche on passe à l'est avec la phrase
de l'été julie gayet beaucoup de gens
espèrent alors que
françois hollande tout laisse un moment
pour les uns peut on vraiment besoin
d'ajouter une vanne à sa presse à 13h
wenn man show en tout cas ce qui est
chouette c'est que dans ce couple là on
sait pas vraiment lequel des deux est le
plus grand sens de l'humour on passe à
l'extrême droite marine le pen alors là
oui ça va pas bien les moyens financiers
sont compliquées elle n'arrive plus à se
payer ces affiches et c'était important
pas mal les dernières affiches on va
l'avoir ici alors moi c'est pas de temps
l'encré et le papier coûte très cher
c'était la licence photoshop qui a coûté
mais voilà résultat elle a dû faire un
appel au dos aux militants et moi ça m'a
ému s'immoler marine le pen a obligé de
faire la manche comme une vieille
roumaine c'est pas ça me touche ça veut
tous et ma dernière info politique je
pense qu'elle a échappé à pas mal de
monde et c'est bête parce que voilà le
titre il est comme ça je change rien
l'élu communiste jean-claude kennedy a
été placé en garde à vue la semaine
dernière après avoir grillé un feu rouge
et percuté un scooter avec sa voiture il
était à zéro g 45 à 19 heures mais le
plus fou c'est que le maire de vitry sur
seine s'appelle jean claude kennedy dans
la série les prénoms qui vont pas super
bien avec les gens ça se pose là on
connaît pas vraiment de john fitzgerald
us on n'en connaît pas mais c'est fou
cette histoire de malédiction du coût
des kennedy
l'attentât de jfk à l'assassinât de
bobby le crash de jungle et maintenant
la murch de jean claude
[Applaudissements]
politique internationale manuel valls
parce que maintenant c'est de la
d'après paris match il est en couple
avec une héritière catalan après avoir
été d'après le même magazine en avril
dernier en couple avec une députée la
république en marche je sais pas si vous
vous rendez compte que manuel valls il
est plus fidèle en politique qu'en amour
saisir le problème il paraît qu'elle est
moche au
japon la cata
les
santés selon un rapport sur l'alcool
pendant la grossesse aujourd'hui un
enfant naît tous les jours en france
avec des troubles liés à l'alcoolisation
foetale donc visiblement je pense que on
va pas manquer de candidats de télé
réalité dans le
[Applaudissements]
médias natacha polony a été nommée
directrice de la rédaction de
l'hebdomadaire marianne mais vous la
féliciterai c'est votre pays
bas dimanche prochain où la féliciter de
ma part c'est vrai que cette somme en a
étonné certains longtemps ce qui aurait
été vraiment étonnant c'est qu'elle soit
nommée directrice de la rédaction de
coiffure magazine dont elle a déjà fait
la une je le rappelle le numéro spécial
ce qu'il ne faut pas faire
je lui dirai que vous avez bien réglée
alors passer à la musique l'album
posthume on l'attend de johnny me
connaît le titre mon pays c'est l'amour
alors évidemment quand on connaît la vie
amoureuse de johnny on suppose quand
même qu'il avait plusieurs passeports
mais
allez les braises
je vous ai faire best-of de brèves de
tout laisser bien à commencer par celle
ci en australie il viole un cheval avec
son consentement
oui donc je teste les prix bas mais là
les airs que c'est ce qu'il a dit au
tribunal et alors que tout le monde sait
évidemment que la seule manière pour un
homme d'être certain du consentement du
cheval c'est d'être passif
[Applaudissements]
animaux toujours en egypte un âne pain
en zèbre dans le zoo du care is high
funèbres ils se sont dit bon on va
peindre un peu lan et cela pose la
question de comment ils ont fait pour
les girafes je
ne sais pas où on passe à la culture oh
là là
à bahreïn
après ce que tu feras payer tous âges là
on a fait un emprunt oui chaque semaine
je propose latérite aller visiter une
exposition au musée j'ai c'est que
c'était des gens d'aller au musée des
choses n'auraient pas pensé à aller voir
et cette semaine nous emmène en bretagne
au frac c'est une jeune artiste
française eva tôt loi qui est exposé
jusqu'à demain donc allez-y demain dans
l'espace public saint briac son dada en
fait c'est l'art abstrait coloré mêlant
l'architecturé le design industriel et
les vêtements elle aime tellement la
couleur que s'ils voulaient être mais
partout on voit sur cette oeuvre là bas
en gros si tu lâches un caméléon dans
son exposition il fait un burn out et on
va voir quelques quelques images
quelques heures a commencé voilà par
celle ci c'est un vêtement il s'agit du
string de plage de pierre ménès
une petite pour la rentrée
c'est l'image qui est drôle et
l'installation regardez comme c'est joli
ça c'est je trouve ça assez beau ce sont
6 ou les différents panneaux de
signalisation routière telles que hugo
loris les a vus la semaine dernière
oeuvres suivantes
je décolle jeu l'école c'était une
blague c'est un jeu pour les enfants
mais son appui alors c'est par contre la
suivante c'est une une de ses hommes je
trouve très très belle équipe aux quand
même une vraie question qu'est ce qui
est arrivé avant l'oeuf ou le rappeur
on sait pas
[Applaudissements]
une autre erreur et qu'on pourrait
sobrement intitulé le viagra du pôle 1
et la dernière c'est peut-être la presse
c'est ma préférée voilà on aurait
évidemment tous reconnu cette superbe
collection d'épilation du maillot de la
chanteuse zaz et
allez donc demain demain c'est votre
dernière chance d'aller voir elsa tôt
loi à l'espace public saint brieuc en
bretagne parce que l'art c'est comme la
politique c'est pas parce qu'on n'y
comprend rien qu'on peut pas parler aux
[Applaudissements]
juges aux oreilles on le trouve ici la
semaine prochaine et sur scène à paris
et dans toute la france
et maintenant c'est l'heure de la promo
qui s'affiche c'est shopping
[Musique]
j'ai beaucoup travaillé la gingn
artiste c'est aussi un code-barres ses
shopi
daphné bürki bon choix
il est ici ce soir pour faire la
promotion de leur émission qui s'appelle
je t'aime et ses terrasses et tous les
jours à 15h sur france 2 et vous passez
en deuxième année ce n'est pas gagné
mais n'ont pas retrouvé votre public
était bien caché mais vous l'avez pas
gagnée vous avez trouvé voilà c'est
quand même rare une émission de l'après
midi de france 2 dure deux ans ils ont
trouvé personne pour vous remplacer la
alors le pitch une omission d'humeur qui
donne la parole aux femmes ah merde et
qui répond aux questions des
téléspectatrices besoin c'est ce que dit
le site de vazy
suivante de cul
sachant mieux ça en plus cela nous avons
engagé des démaquillants oui andré auger
le prix offert j'ai pris une assurance
ni tout à chaque fin d'émission est dit
mais quand est ce qu'on peut mais
l'amour tous ensemble comme ça pour
libre alors il est désespéré huit mois
passés chose en plus que c'est vrai
qu'il est des poils partout
on m'a dit ça alors on va regarder à
quoi çà
et là c'est un grand moment parce que je
cherche quel fond qui revenue quoi
bientôt c'est non
buté voulu à ml ghb nom
andré alors je vous le dit andré ce que
vous avez en fait il s'agit d'un sachet
conçu pour être introduit dans le vagin
sais pas
quand je suis stressée j'ai des
élections impossibles à contrôler c'est
très gênant dans ma vie professionnelle
et ma vie sociale que faire docteur j p
je vais faire comme caroline diamant
veinards
je suis tombé une fois dessus une fille
qui m'a dit vas-y tu dis - des mots et
jeudi vilaine
habitude ça va durer ben bof certains
hommes sera intégralement pour que leur
phallus paraissent plus grands
exactement comme roman raccourci bécaud
regarde du haut ça fait plus rien su
c'est juste
la dernière fois que j'ai fait l'amour
avec mon petit ami j'ai eu un gaz
pendant l'acte depuis je n'ose plus
l'approcher tellement j'ai honte et ça
fait trois semaines qu'on n'a pas fait
l'amour et des mois et vous a pas une
histoire de perrine et musclé coeur
parce qu'on n'est pas un inconnu en fait
quand on fait l'amour ce n'est pas le
monde c'est vrai que le bruit peut être
identique et donc peut-être que vous
confondez avec le pet vaginale parce que
c'est le même bruit mais la faiblesse
n'a vraiment que
les services publics c'est top
salut les terriens à ses lecteurs en
chef samuel en fait c'est le cas c'est
bien oui non mais ya pas que ça non
dimanche un condensé que chez les
hémorroïdes
du tout mettre dans la bande-annonce pas
mais alors tout ce que je vais dire mais
là les grands pays qui parle de l'amour
au sens là bien joué la bomba et on
était sûr et geely prévisible de fratus
est visible je sais je suis un petit peu
enfin carrière
comme celle à laquelle on se lâchera pas
non j'en ai jusque auront jusqu'au
cercueil tous les êtres jusqu au
crématorium c'est quand même pratique
ses poches un passant par toutes les
missions sont allés au toilettes
cette saison grande nouveauté évidemment
c'est que vous interviewer les les stars
dans leur lit ou dans votre lit et oui
c'est une façon de mettre à l'aise
différemment ouais ouais de parler de
son intimité de sa vie dans une chambre
vous dis c'était un lieu où la parole se
libère il est vrai que maintenant ça se
passe bien donc ça va très bien c'est un
ami et alors on dit que j'avais remplacé
marianne james dans prodige on dit plein
de choses mais en fait j'ai pas le droit
de dire les choses ah ouais vous n'avez
pas le droit de dire mais en tout cas
j'ai pas droit de dire que en effet je
vais grandir à aa ont nommé en prime sur
plusieurs formes et c'est normal à
droite dire les couleurs je vais vous
dire un truc moi je vous ai vus aux
victoires de la musique oui dans une
situation extrêmement compliquée après
on verra bien car le dogue horrible que
vous avez meublé j'ai un peu plus que
meubles et j'ai fait une belle déco un
ouais ça c'est vrai que nous ayons
d'écossé un marché en plus fouillis
magnéto sa part
nous avons une petite panne c'est des
choses qui arrivent quelquefois je pense
que c'est l'équipe jaune a été tué ont
tous à bosser
ces enfants on est pour leur dire de
bien se tenir alors évidemment voilà on
va remettre les machines en marche je
pense que tout devrait fonctionner c'est
normal qu'ils des petites pannes ça
s'appelle le direct connaissez les joies
tout ça vous avez ce qu'on va faire
est-ce que vous commencez à avoir faim
ou soif dans cette salle
alors je vais prendre les commandes j'ai
préparé des sandwichs si vous pouvez
m'apporter des sandwichs il vous plaît
un ce serait gentil on est sur du
jambon-beurre vallone merci beaucoup de
ces gentils voyez quand je demande
quelque chose c'était exceptionnel
tout ce produit merci la technique
alors bon bah on y va on va se promener
donc quelqu'un voudrait un petit jambon
éventuellement à on est par là bas alors
désolé je vais par là bas non à bahia
des enfants s'est voulu questionner dit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
normand et voilà on se retrouve après la
vue pour les cas les plus jeunes
[Applaudissements]
mon aventure
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir les terriens du sein oh
dans l'émission que vous permet de
savoir quel jour on est toujours encore
banni de la vie me retire
2 sinon porte j'ai tenu et de l'ordre
[Musique]
si tu n'en sais pas et maintenant c'est
l'heure de lardy quiz
[Musique]
alors dans son film stéphane plaza joue
un homme habité par l'esprit d'albert
einstein voilà alors cette semaine l'a
redit quiz est consacrée évidemment au
génie en hommage
c'est les deux c'est grave et de tension
si vous pensez vous appuyez sur le
buzzer on essaye
c'est d'un fils
ça c'est toi à d'accord d'accord cession
de droit
très bien il est très court vous êtes
prêts première question quel prénom a
été inventé par william shakespeare à
daphné
jessica mon juliette ou nabila
juliette non
jessica jessica bravo
[Applaudissements]
compléter cette phrase de cédric villani
les maths c'est mieux que la politique
qu une séance de yoga qu'un éclair au
chocolat comme sex
voulons
qu'elles étaient l'adresse de victor
hugo impasse de misérables rue des
châtiments place de jersey ou avenue
victor hugo
victor hugo et en métal victor hugo
avenue victor hugo en son avenir à
volants bravo c'est le gros
bon sens sur facebook pendant les mêmes
réponses tu viens moi souvent un malade
et qu'elle oeuvre a été composé par
mozart vient goûter mon boudoir
plaisir de jouir au quand il pète il
trouve son slip
lèche mois le cul
normal et l'appui à vos romans pièces
jointes et
moi qui suit un direct et scato voisard
mimosas risques à tous et en allemand
die l'aic miche ichard ouais enfin c'est
la même chose
je suis en
tout cas non quelle affirmation est
vraie concernant pablo picasso il a des
ancêtres communs avec andré citroën il a
eu dix enfants cachés il est est
daltonien ou pascal obispo est un
anagramme de pablo picasso
si ça a marché devenu alors je vais même
plus quelle les trois premières
[Applaudissements]
la nagra oui non
si stepanek - première se pressent que
la dernière un bouquin sur les annales
des clés connais notamment picasso
basque alors plus qu'à l'aube ispo -
quels furent les derniers mots d'albert
einstein amer d'autant de merde mais
c'est ma réponse
je me suis trompé la bonne formule c'est
pas égales mc2a pouvez-vous me raser la
moustache ou aucun ses derniers mots
était en allemand et l'infirmière à ses
côtés ne parlait pas la
dernière il a dit
c'est pourquoi il tient la langue sur la
photo einstein non parce qu'en fait il
le faisait chier les mecs les paparazzi
les journalistes tout le monde l'emmerdé
et il aurait tiré la langue et c'est
resté célèbre en fait c'est une
rébellion génie militaire entre la
mondiaux quitté médiatique que peut-on
trouver au musée galilée à florence le
pyjama bleu galilée une mèche de cheveux
de galilée un morceau du doigt de
galilée ou le prépuce de
gager faux
abbas hussein
comme rick coiffure un morceau de doigt
mais bravo
[Applaudissements]
c'est majeur de sa main droite et c'est
un rock and roll il ya les moules et
ouais gagner et la maintenance et le
super banco c'est à dire que celui mais
seuls à gagner qui gagne a tout gagné
j'aurais mieux fait de répondre à ces le
ciel fm faire in the stone la meilleure
groupe
avec des compagnies
[Musique]
alors quelle seconde à inventer thierry
ardisson
quiz de ginai complètement
qui a toute la montée la télévision
marié michel denisot qui avait dit un
truc très drôle ardisson avec le micro
qu'il n'a pas inventé c'est un but aux
marrons mais attention en se pensant aux
caprices à 2 caprice des dieux comme
génial il est fou il
n'est pas mort il est fou afflelou il
est fou
salakis au bon lait de brebis ou quand
c'est trop c'est trop biko
quand c'est trop c'est trop
alors donc dans cette émission les
gagnants darby quiz way ont droit à un
éloge par thierry ardisson et les autres
c'est ma fille qui va faire alors
seulement je n'ai qu'à dernier attention
elle est fun elle est drôle elle a la
patate
ne ratez pas daphné bürki tous les après
midi à 15h dit sur france 2 elle est
morte
sans oublier que d'affluer très bien
entouré pour son émission puisqu'il est
accompagné entre autres pas andré
manoukian dit dédé doigts de fée le
grand spécialiste du plaisir féminin
de la bonne humeur du cul des bons plans
du cul des conseils psy du cul des
astuces de co2 du q vos témoignages bref
ne manquez pas je t'aime et c'est une
émission pour se faire du bien tous les
jours à 15h10 sur france 2 les après
midi c'est daphné burki
[Applaudissements]
alors j'attends là la promo de
stéphane donc tu as joué dans un film
première connerie est ce que tu veux
nous en parler
non merci voilà
ça fait du monde ça va se jouer
longtemps un film voilà et ça va ça va
être bien non pas un goût de se faire
chier à regarder les graisses pour aller
voir cette merde
c'est pas vrai parce que le bouquin
était bas je vends bien je fais sûr que
le film et non à l'écran en parler c'est
la suite de shopping
[Musique]
ses fans c'est à vous oui donc vous avez
le premier rôle dans le film d'olivier
femmes covered qui s'appelle j'ai perdu
albert avec julie ferrier et josiane
balasko qui sort le 12 septembre donc
voilà c'est shopping donc on vous écoute
le pitch le pitch est en fait de blessés
déjà didier van cauwelaert kkk
transposer son livre qui a été un succès
il ya josiane balasko julie ferrier
bernard le coq musique de michel legrand
et natalie dessay déjà donc il ya une
pléiade de très bons acteurs et en fait
voilà c'est sur la vie après la mort et
albert einstein a toujours pensé qu'il y
avait une continuité après la mort et
donc on a une voyante médium julie
ferrier qui ont fait trop qui est très
demandé et qui va s'en servir un petit
peu pour pour sa vie personnelle elle
abrite l'esprit d'albert et de shan est
donc lui va être vexé et va donc décidé
de partir chez quelqu'un d'autre un
apiculteur joué par mois un looser un
dépressif mais donc il est avec les
abeilles et ça va intéresser albert
einstein parce qu'il a toujours dit que
sans les abeilles le monde va s'arrêter
c'est vraiment survivrait deux ans soyez
prêt c'est monsieur imagine que vous a
choisi parce que j'ai une tête à
héberger l'estrie d'albert einstein je
pense que c'est pour ça ou y avait de la
place pour héberger quelques uns je
vendrai il pouvait me squatter
gratuitement roi vous êtes bien en rôle
mais en même temps j'ai pas dû faire
beaucoup d c'est parce que les agents
immobiliers pour jouer la comédie y a
pas besoin de ça je trouve que c'est
quand même normalement un agent
immobilier vend du rêve là j'ai plutôt
un
c'est un dépressif et en plus ce qui est
très important en tout cas pour moi
c'est que c'est canal+ donc ça n'a rien
à voir avec la filiale de m6 donc il ya
eu un vrai casting il ya eu pas eu à
passer l'oral qu'à financer canada sinon
c'est quand elle veut une participation
de m6 évidemment mais voilà ces voix là
et quelques il ya eu un vrai casting a
pas eu de passerelles m6 ont préféré le
voyage tout de suite des comédiens de
l'intérieur bon on va regarder à quoi ça
ressemble magnéto serge
c'est gentil de me recevoir j'ai deux
mauvais pressentiment par exemple et une
en bleu me faire écraser projeté pas
négatif c'est sûr
je suis déjà trompé vous êtes une chanel
à canal par lequel s'exprime avec
quelqu'un du monde des esprits oui il
s'appelle comment cet informateur je
n'ai pas leur a dévoilé son identité
vous avez déjà permis d'éviter 14
attentats formation cible 13
vous désirez
j'entends une voix une seule toujours là
même qui me dit tout ce qui se passe
autour de moi tu perdu albert
perdu une guerre qu'est ce qui se passe
pourquoi tu me parles genre quoi un
vieux avec une voix douce et un accent
moi ça lasse péruvienne un falafel de
yaka tories ça marche ça
comment il a deviné à midi j'ai pris
votre commande mais je n'ai pas pris que
truc commandes seront pas que c'était
contagieux la voyant son c'est une
entité qui m'a quittée pour vous chez
vous vraiment dans ma tête c'est qu'il
sait d'esprit la mort c'est un esprit
d'un niveau très supérieur albert
c'est un type qui s'appelle albert et
qui est rentré en moi et vous étiez
croissante absolument pas
j'ai perdu l'avant même si votre premier
film c'est mon premier prime elle buvait
du thé avec les formes d'art dans le
hall gill qui a pas un gros carton en
plus sur france 2 et la maintenance et
le cinéma vous aurez sait plus quoi bein
je gère et et quatre mois pour ce film
pas de télé pas d'immobilier rien du
tout pour vraiment à l'inversé il faut
bien sûr il faire la chose est bien
racontée dans cette émission la dernière
que vous voyez en fait un jour un
producteur the lady je te donne le rôle
et à condition que tu fasses une petite
gâterie ouais ouais et la lime on a
demandé deux bombes à bon bout d'un
moment j'ai dit j'ai 48 ans j'y vais
kouassi qui concourent je me suis dit je
vais prendre ton savoir bas bien sûr
c'est plus facile de vendre un film un
appartement va se defendre l'appartement
et du film je pense que ce film là il y
aura pas besoin de le vendre parce que
déjà que tous les artistes qui a deux
dents mais qu'ils considèrent trop là
c'est un ovni voilà alors qu'il est très
marrant c'est que sur m6 vous continuez
à faire une carrière très brillante et
la veille de la sortie du film le 11
septembre donc sur m6 en prime time il
ya un numéro inédit de recherche
appartement ou maison donc c'est la
totale quoi c est vous avez ils ont été
intelligents m6 ils n'ont pas mis le
même jour que la sortie et non sa
descente en recharge tour
alors ce qui est extraordinaire avec
vous c'est que vous avez vraiment
changer l'image des agents immobiliers
parce que avant avant vous ont pensé que
c'était des escrocs et aujourd'hui on
sait que c'est des escrocs rigolo
[Musique]
j'accumule vous êtes beau oui hall a
déjà battu devant soi et souriant vous
êtes sympathique vous bossez dans la
mode
vous avez l'air heureux ouais je n'ai
pas peur de choquer les gens de la mode
en ayant l'air heureux
lorsque regarder quand même quand on
voit les gens de la mode ils font quand
même la gueule
nous vous souriez en plus de ça c'était
extrêmement talentueux
alors on parle du retour de la rougeole
en france vous êtes la nouvelle
coqueluche
le chapeau bombe a fait un énorme succès
cet été on regarde le chapeau l'angle
bombe à
personne
c'est incroyable alors vous avez fait
des procès non il coule non sam à 13 10
le plus
alors la question c'est de savoir
à
elle s'est même pas de la télé c'est la
téloche vous l'avez pas fait ça là n'ont
ils jamais nommé d'attenté
non oui on donne
tout le grand chapeau de youyous il ya
beaucoup de stars qui portent vos
chapeaux vos costumes et ses zombies
quoi méfaits des vêtements portables
alors évidemment ces pratiques alors il
a marqué notre ami a marqué les esprits
cet été avec un défi des hommes gadio
ouais à marseille chez moi ça dans le
sud on va regarder manier tous
suis plus fort que le machistador de m
c'est un beau gosse évidemment que je m
en salle à sable dans la crise 250 unis
mais le reste c'est la presse ouais
j'suis encore chez mes parents
cette façon j'ai 30 ans je suis abonné à
casting entre lui et maximales ya des
mes paroles c'est pas si mal c'est la
carte ugc pathé et comme ça je paye
jamais à tanger pas un goal monde
je suis
quand on suit
c'est hier la calanque de sormiou à
marseille s'est passé comment c'est très
drôle parce que j'avais envie de défiler
à paris envoie lagerfeld île où le grand
palais ils dépensent des millions
d'euros vous faites ça sur la plage et
si j'ai mal j'avais envie d'être injuste
un endroit paradisiaque à avec du son à
gauche à droite et et ces mecs là vous
n'êtes pas trop d'accent anglais non
j'ai voulu perdre à moi aussi je voulais
le parisien et voilà dans la campagne je
me forçais à le perdre quand je suis
arrivé à paris mais je vais me axe agge
away j'ai perdu aussi sonné alors pour
rendre hommage à marseille que j'aurais
pu faire une collection entièrement en
sacs poubelles
les biens se battent ou les t-shirts
paris en tant que y avait
alors dit pas parisien évidemment vous
ai pas fait d'école de mode c'est pas
beau c'est dans une maison de couture et
le comble de tout c'est que les parents
de notre ami simon étaient agriculteurs
papa était dans les épinards karine le
marchand
c'est pourquoi
il me dit moi je veux vendre parce que
mes parents étaient commerçants en fait
ouais c'est ça moi je me samedi j'étais
sur les marchés parisien et grands
parents voilà à les aider et j'ai
toujours eu ça en fait quand j'ai créé
ce sont ma marque il fallait que je
vende maghrébins collection pour payer
la deuxième donc voilà j'ai toujours eu
ce sens voilà très et réalise et bien
que tu as croisé des parents
agriculteurs mais à l'âge de 3 ans notre
mère vous inscrire dans une agence de
mannequins j'ai fait dire qu pour
pampers au carambar on va les voilà
c'est le petit si nous regardent comme
il était
donc à 18 ans vous décidez débarqué à
paris aida peut mettre deux couches là
[Applaudissements]
débarqué à paris pour entrer dans un
mode mais malheureusement après votre
mère se tue dans un accident de voiture
il ya une très belle chose vraiment très
émouvante c'est quand vous redescendez
vous attendez à trouver votre mère sur
un lit d'hôpital dans cette année sur
son lit de mort ça que vous vous couchez
à côté d'elle c'est extraordinaire ça
pour la sentir prendre l'énergie en fait
mais tout ça tout ça de sa manche en
effet j'en ai fait cette histoire-là de
dix ans de mode j'en ai fait j'en ai
fait mon sourire que je l'a jamais parce
qu'on m'a dit de sourire que c'était la
plus belle arme et c'est simple
jacquemus c'est son nom est un essai
ouais c'est ça ou ça génial ça vous a
donné une énergie folle pour monter à
paris j'étais fou voilà et vous dites
avec une phrase positive moi j'étais fou
j'ai rien laisser passer la preuve que
vous avez raison alors après trois mois
dans cette école de mode vous cassez pas
ce qu'il dit les étudiants semblaient
être là par hasard alors que moi je
jouais ma vie et que ma mère avait voulu
vendre sa voiture pour payer les études
de
10000 euros l'année dans une école voilà
dans ma campagne dans mon champ j'avais
tellement rêvé de cette école ce moment
là j'avais l'impression que j'allais
être entouré de passionnés qu'on a les
genres chanter qu'on allait créer machin
et je me suis retrouvé là je dis waouh
en fait c'est juste une école alors ce
que vous faites il va au marché
saint-pierre il achète du tissu pour
faire des robes et comme il sait pas
coudre il est fait coûte par une
couturière de mon manque les petites
verrines d'au moins une retouche aldrin
le retoucheuse de rio et combien tu me
prends pour faire une jupe une jupe
savoir de 10 ans 57 cents euros je me le
fais et voilà c'est comme ça et là que
j'ai fait la première collection de le
publier sur facebook et là la presse m'a
appelé et ça a commencé la commune c'est
comme ça et en 2011 vous faîtes le buzz
avec un rating que j'adore c'est jacques
lui sont en grève magnéto se réfugier
phil tenez vous prêtes emmanuelle alt
rédactrice de vogue france à la rive
l'amas de la mode la mode la mode la
mode la mode la mode la mode manager
chez moi j'accuse jeunes créateurs il
était avec ses copines il porte ce
modèle ouais ce mois ci j'ai dans le
[ __ ] y sélectionner les vagues italie
je serais content emballages monde mais
si je devais montrer une vision de la
mode autrement c'est des ouvrières
bizarre en mode mais pourtant ça marche
voilà je suis content d'avoir attiré
votre attention
non mais emmanuel seck se serrent la
main devant les caméras
vraiment
j'ai dû commencer
kenzo passage viviane qu'ils
essaieraient avec une machine à coudre
avec ses copains et ses copines qui
donnait un coup de main gb louboutin qui
commençait à dessiner ses pompes et où
vous avez vous avez quelque chose comme
ça si vous y croyez ce qui est plus beau
mois pour moi enfin en tout cas si si
qui malgré l'énergie de sa mère est en
fait ils essaient de sourire alors qu'il
a son deuil sur lui qui fait tout aussi
pour que sa mère depuis ce sourire en
eau toi donc ça c'est ce qu'il ya en
parlant mais oui toi le film sort le
jour anniversaire du décès de tom
exactement donc c'est pour ça que je
joue enfin c'est des choses un tel cas
il ya une vie et tout c'est que maman
quand on a eu la chance d'avoir tous et
amour etc eh ben on essaye de tout faire
pour qu'elle soit encore plus fier de
moi là haut et apparemment c'est ce qui
lui a donné une énergie qui
l'assaillent adoubé par le monde de la
mode les mêmes fins celle ci avec
emmanuel macron aussi à lui s'il y en a
marre on veut le même ministre de la
mode oui c'est vrai il annoncé hier en
tout entre philippe besson stéphane bern
y'a pas de soucis minutes du logement
voudra-t-il tr min ce de quoi tirer des
armées
pour bombarder des pays
paris
[Musique]
et en terme et vous l'avez vous l'avez
sur le bout de la langue ouais le bundle
[Applaudissements]
attention alors tout le monde joue
contre baffie ouais bah oui il est trop
fort enfin non tu m'as marie sissi j'ai
beaucoup veiller à l'envi branché
l'habitacle car on tenait de ta mort
ouais j'accorde masse
de
voilà alors le vainqueur devra célébrer
sa victoire comme un joueur de foot qui
marque un but ont relevé le maillot sur
la thur le bleu maillot tu fais ça tu
fais
[Applaudissements]
attention on y va emma
[Musique]
non
vous aurez remarqué la maison vide donc
c'est un blague thèse qui est dédié
comme le jeu soulignant que tu es là
plata
[Musique]
attention et moi
j'aime bien ah ouais je connais sa mère
dormait
[Musique]
j'aurais pu le trouver sinon ça va si
bon grammer numérique non non non pas du
tout est malade cash et l'émission de
valérie damidot c'est pas du tout la
mienne celle inverse
attention
attention et ma
femme on sera éliminés
[Applaudissements]
m
georges
je t'aime elle ressemble ma fille quand
je la vois jouer ni non elle vient de se
marier
ressemble à ma mère c'est troublant
c'est qu'on
assimile à un peu comme toi il a trouvé
avant que ça commence à winona blunt est
le première seconde si je connais la
musique lui a jamais fait rock béton
mais merde attention ça ça m'étonnerait
qu'ils connaissent pas ce que c'est
vraiment ignoble attention et m'en
aller
eddy mitchell
mambé salvador
d'abord
aimer
on
n'est pas obligé d'écouter toute la
chanson non plus c'est pour jouer
emma
ah oui ça
c'est la vraie
magie c'est quoi
[Musique]
attention
si quelqu'un souffre j'ai fait évacuer
la salle
quand même cette époque or le prochain
il est pour toi tu qu'on va comprendre
pourquoi il m'a
avec ça
non c'est la fille du sud elle est venue
son plateau il ya 18 ans là elle
s'appelle marie mcee
[Musique]
mais
attention ça c'est pour toi c'est ton
âge
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il vient d'arriver on peut donner un
point à chacun aussi de saluer chacun ce
serait un poids pour laurent
attention bon on passe la prochaine
parce que c'est francis la dame et
honnêtement tout va bien j'ai pas envie
d'être franchi
attention on passait le suivre
patron soir
ja
jamais
oui attention avant dernière attention
se concentre
[Musique]
et musées mais trois les gens croient
dans son sketch
[Applaudissements]
centrale
attention donc maintenant c'est de super
bons coups a dit allez les gars a tout
gagné et
mayer
[Musique]
et
ça
[Musique]
c'était le jingle de superbes à trouver
alors je vais gagner bon attention vous
êtes prêt celui ou celle qui trouve a
tout gagné et sera obligé de faire une
célébration de joueurs de foot donc tout
intérêt à gagner que ça et non
oui le pénitencier
les quatre les si les cadeaux
je connais sa mère devenue marque la
personne ne
sait pas
jeanne rose des eaux
connexes à est ce que quelqu'un connaît
la réponse
bravo monsieur bravo
oui
c'était derrière lui samedi avec michel
onfray
intérêts
deux grammes d'argent
pas plus alors on a vite
ceux qui m'ont aidé à bien cette
émission à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]
les corrections de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu